[Music]
foreign
s were not the only creatures to be seen
in the trailer of the mag to the trench
there were also other creatures and
another one that was truly Sinister in
appearance and terrifying to look at and
that is the octopus creature which we
will aptly call the Kraken so let us
dedicate this video to unraveling its
Origins its size and purpose so let's
get to it now let's first discuss about
its appearance and its Origins as well
as species type it was hard to notice at
first glance but when the human
characters in the trailer went down to
the trench to investigate an anomaly
they dived in with powered exoskeleton
suits like that will change anything and
one of them unknowingly awaken a
gigantic cephalopod creature with bright
yellowish eyes that had slang pupils
reminiscent of the eyes of an octopus
this creature also had a bulbous head
and dark gray black coloration and most
of all it had long tentacles with
suction cups it then attacked the
unfortunate member of the Expedition
crew killing him and leaving nothing but
a helmet falling down to the ocean floor
later in the other scenes of the trailer
it was seen with its extremely long
tentacles attacking a beach resort and
even managing to grab a helicopter
putting it down to the Sea
any biological expert would say that
this is a species of octopus and since I
did have a minor subject in Zoology in
college I too would confirm it
um but for all intents and purposes it
will be called a kraken since they are
also cephalopod Monsters of myths and
legends and it does fit the role of one
maybe it was trapped in the trench
ecosystem after years of terrifying
galleys and attacking medieval ships way
back in the past this is pure
speculation however as it might also be
another undiscovered species that have
existed in the oceans for millions of
years as you know the ocean is still
relatively untouched and unknown we
humans have more knowledge about the
surface of the Moon than the ocean floor
that is a fact
if it is indeed a kraken then it would
explain the medieval myths of such
creatures in many cultures around the
world including Greek nors and Pacific
Islander Tales if it is a kraken then
such a monster would be based on
something biological this creature would
definitely fit the shoe so in reality
why on their fossilized remains and why
are cephalopods hard to be accounted for
in the ancient bars and the answer to
that is because squids and octopus
mainly are soft-bodied creatures with no
skeletons whatsoever and the only heart
structure in their Anatomy is just the
beak which is made out of keratin the
same material found in our nails so I
guess these would not be easy to
fossilize and hence no evidence of their
existence will be saved especially in
the oceans where all biomass is recycled
so back to the movie this is a truly
massive creature one that even Rivals
the Megalodon sharks in size how big is
it well that is the reason why mind Q
exists do unravel the size mystery of
movie monsters and also other kinky
stuff in the scene where the crew member
turned his bag on the Kraken it can be
estimated that he was roughly 15 to 20
feet away from the creature the eyes of
the Kraken was still roughly the same
size as the guy's head from that
distance so by that reference point we
can state that the eyes alone were 60 to
70 centimeters wide or roughly more than
two feet therefore if the Kraken had the
same eye to head proportions of an
octopus that would give a head size
alone at roughly 20 to 25 feet or 6 to
7.6 meters long since the head would be
bulbous and elongated at the back now
looking at the scene of the Kraken
attacking the beach resort at one point
of time we can see its technicals
reaching out from the sea to grab a
helicopter in midair therefore this
creature's Monumental in total body
length or size the aircraft was at least
50 feet or 15 meters in the air and it
grabbed it like it was nothing so would
another portion of the tentacles still
underwater we can say or estimate that
the Kraken has an enormous reach easily
over 70 feet or 21 meters therefore the
tentacles would be of that length that
same length now couple them with the 20
to 25 feet head we have a cephalopod
monster that is nearly 100 feet long
around the same size as the Myers grid
from the Kong Skull Island movie and to
be clear this is just an initial
estimate we have to see the entire body
of the Kraken first and that will only
happen when the movie is released so
with that size is it a rival predatory
species in the trench ecosystem and will
it fight the Meg so in our previous
video we estimated the size of the
Megalodon sharks watch it to know the
exact measurements of the three
specimens all we can say is that the
Kraken is roughly the size of the mech
from the first movie so it could pose a
threat to the smaller mags in the trench
and it could also be hunted by big
specimens such as the way of nature eat
or be eaten therefore in a way it is a
rival species but is it big enough to
kill the adult specimens not really as
these mechs can just rip it to shreds
but it can suffocate one however by
calling around the body of a shark and
prevent it from swimming therefore in
turn restricting its gills from ticking
in oxygen as a shark's way of
respiration is to constantly move to get
oxygen into the gills therefore by doing
this it could theoretically kill a Meg
and that is why this creature is so
interesting
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam